Houston officials are surveying the
damage left behind by Harvey Mayor
Sylvester Turner took a flight over his
devastated city yesterday the White
House estimates the storm is affected
around a hundred thousand Texas homes
thirty-seven thousand utility customers
in Houston are still without power this
morning DeMarco Morgan is in downtown
Houston
DeMarco good morning good morning Mary
so floodwaters are starting to recede
and that means city services have
started to come back online but now
starts the grim task of trying to
account for all of the people that did
not survive the storm going door-to-door
search and rescue teams fanned out
across neighborhoods that have been
inundated by the flooding we're finding
out just how much damage there is if
there's any civilians that have been
left behind one section of the city was
fully searched thursday five more should
be finished today
as more neighborhoods dry out some
people are venturing back into their
flood damaged homes water came up they
ripped up waterlogged drywall and
carpets
[Music]
destroyed furniture and debris piled up
on the streets we're out of here my
wife's from San Antonio and she doesn't
want to go through this anymore and
we're done
calls for help are diminishing the
police department performed just three
high water rescues between Wednesday
night and Thursday morning we received
about 30 missing persons reports since
the storm began we have cleared 11 of
those already we still have 19 cases
that we are still looking for to
Houstons airports reopened for
commercial flights some public
transportation services also resumed the
mayor says the Toyota Center shelter
will likely be closed by end of day the
people still there will be moved to the
Convention Center where eight thousand
remain down from a high of 10,000 don't
bet against Houston don't bet against
Harris County we are coming back and
we're coming back strong officials say
the water still pulls a dangerous risk
they're telling people not to drive
through flooded roads and also watch out
for the water because it can make you
sick and it also can dank contains I
should say dangerous wildlife we
actually just spotted a snake not too
far from where we are standing so you
want to be extremely careful and also
watch out for the water because it also
has bad chemicals that can make you sick
Maurice it's ok DeMarco Morgan thank you